you know coming off vecon i got a lot of
feelings
i just really
really believe in what i see
and i have like
just incredible appetite and ambition to
try to scale it
i see a clear path to how we can get
there which is grounded on building up
self-esteem
countering hate with love
right now we're so hate on hate
triggered
right i'm like i go triggered and i
heard like every single person
says you suck it hurts
everyone i wonder if i can get others to
see themselves the way i do which is
just like a
like kind of like an empty
pipe i'm just an empty pipe it's like
you give me accolades my mom you [ __ ] on
me you just don't know me it's all empty
it's just like i think of ego confidence
and humility as a triangle it's not even
like a triangle because usually that's
like a thing together it's like just
these consolation of like
three things that like the game is like
if you can just go focus just on hey you
have self-esteem like i'm a good person
i'm doing the best i can
doing the best i can
and
and humility like if it's going well
being like yeah okay there's been
there's eight billion people on earth
i'm sure there's
billions that are doing it better than
me you know better looking me nicer me
smarter me if you can play on that you
win if you go to ego which is just
insecurity it's all over
i think a lot about that
it's like ego which is just pure
insecurity like you think you're [ __ ]
so then you make pretend that you're
good
you think you're [ __ ] so it's lack of
self-confidence
so then you spend all your time [ __ ]
on everybody else and fake pretending
that you're good
posturing all to protect that you're
weak the reason i give so much trust you
know this
is because i'm strong you [ __ ] me cool
you lost not me
compassion is really
like the difference between empathy and
compassion is something i've been
spending a lot of time for
there's a lot of people who like are
nice and they're like there's like a lot
of sensitive people that are nice but
their weakness and their insecurity
creates scenarios where they lash out
and aren't nice but it's a funny one
because if you're sensitive and like
empathetic you do have feelings you
you're kind you actually have a lot of
good
but it's your weakness and your
sensitivity that's causing your back
it's like some of the [ __ ] i heard at
vcon this guy's got to get in he's got
18 000 followers
what does that even mean like who talks
like that everyone wants to go there so
fast
like posturing people's intent is
selfish because they're trying to plug
holes my mother in my circumstance
plugged my holes before they started so
i'm a grown up with no holes of course i
have holes but like
[ __ ] a lot less than a lot of people
people live their whole life trying to
close their holes i'm like the holes are
closed i'll [ __ ] it
let me go
close other people's holes
i'm [ __ ] closing other people's holes
so i think a lot about these thoughts
like
because when you're confident
but humble
you're just balancing
you know
you're purpling
purpling
also if you lack self-esteem
you're in trouble
like that's just if you don't think
you're good
it's over
before it started
you lost when you woke up
[Music]
now a lot of people that are sensitive
or soft or insecure
lash
because they want to tap first yeah
because in their mind they're like if i
stay passive here they're going to hurt
me so i'm going to hurt you first
just hurt
you know a lot of managers insecure
they're like i'm gonna put down that
person right now let me start beating
them down
make them weaker so they don't get me it
all starts with you
[Music]
i'm like
hey because
nobody's doing [ __ ] to me
it's not [ __ ] happening all eight
billion can be like you know we all
decided you suck i'm like cool let's go
give me first eight billion you know
what i mean which is why i want to get
everybody understand you're good like
seriously everybody like [ __ ] man i
really talked to camera like
[ __ ] it like jesus like what
everybody else thinks too like you're
doing the best you can like
you'll be better tomorrow like beating
yourself up it makes no sense
there's just no logic to it i understand
why you do it somebody you know
your dad told you you sucked you suck
like i get it
but it's just not true
it's not true that you suck
it's not
you think you suck which then triggers
everything else you can just change your
mind
you can
you can love yourself
how can you be kind to anybody else if
you're not kind of yourself
how it's impossible you have no energy
to give
this crazy combo once were
i was like you just wanted
the money and all this and i was like
you have health
i was like do you want to know about my
knowing their friends who have terminal
cancer you want to switch
no
why not focus
[Music]
i just got a lot of good feelings from
like because i feel really
reinvigorated like i feel more ambitious
look i'm like okay let's [ __ ] go
like
one person at a time yeah like it
doesn't feel daunting to me i'm a good
bricklayer
at 22 it didn't feel daunting to me that
i was gonna give a decade and a half to
my dad and then start same now i'm like
okay
6.2 billion people not happy let's go
one two i'm gonna get you today i'm
gonna get you today tomorrow i'm gonna
get somebody else and in four days i'm
gonna get somebody else watching this
in 19 days and in 27 days i'm gonna get
somebody who's gonna get somebody else
that i couldn't have gotten to brick my
brick i break my brick my brick by brick
it's just a game of lemonade
it's the most binary simple game on
earth
people just want to be loved but
they don't realize they have to start
with themselves and they have to accept
self-awareness
you're not going to be an athlete you're
not going to be a billionaire you're not
going to be a supermodel cool
go be something else and that leads to
everything the reason i've always
innovated is i'm not scared
got to figure out how to get everybody
to love themselves
which is why we have to change success
from money
because not everybody has skills to make
money
[Music]
but we can teach everybody to have
skills in being content and happy what
they have gratitude
i really want it
it's a game of why not
why wouldn't you want the world to be
after
it's a better world